>>NFL BET YOU LE.
ARE BAC ANDT IS T
VISIS RNDS  T
TH DIVION ROUS OF T.
AYOF.
HOW AEEELI,ELLA
>> FANTTIC.
TH MAY BESTEEK HE
PLAYOFFS.
IT IS THE DIVISION ROUNDS.
IT IS THE TEAMS WHO SHOULD BE
HERE AND A LOT OF BIG GAMES.
I AM A BIG DIVISION GUY.
>> IT IS THE WEEKEND OF DALLAS,
COWBOYS, RIGHT?
>> WE'RE STARTING EARLY.
>> HEY, THIS WHOLE TIME I DIDN'T
EVEN SEE YOU HAD THAT ON, BRO, I
SWEAR.
>> A STAR RIGHT HERE.
>> I WOULD HAVE PUT MINE ON IF I
WOULD HAVE KNEW THAT.
WE ARE STARTING THIS EARLY.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
THAT'S HOW WE'RE GONNA START
THIS SHOW.
IT IS THE DIVISION ROUND.
LIKE MY MAN SAM SAID, SOME TEAMS
ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO BE HERE, IE
MY MAN ALL THE WAY TO THE FAR
RIGHT.
HIS TEAM IS NOT SUPPOSED TO BE
HERE, BUT THEY'RE HERE, AND THEY
PLAY MY TEAM TOMORROW.
WE'RE GONNA GET TO THAT.
WE HAVE A MATCH UP TODAY AND WE
HAVE SOME MATCH UPS TODAY, BUT
BEFORE WE GET INTO THE MATCH UP
AND BEFORE WE NEED YOU GUYS TO
HELP US WITH OUR PARLAY, I HAVE
TO INTRODUCE THE MAN NEXT TO ME
AND THE MAN NEXT TO HIM.
LET'S START OFF LIKE THIS.
I AM GREG IVORY AND NEXT TO ME
IS THE MAN I LIKE TO CALL THE
MAN, THE MYTH, THE LEGEND.
I CALL HIM S DOT AND A BUNCH OF
THINGS.
YOU MAY KNOW HIM AS SAM
RICHMOND.
NEXT TO HIM IS THE MAN ON THIS
SHOW WE LIKE TO CALL PRODUCER
RYAN.
WE'RE GIVING OUT OUR BEST BETS
LATER ON IN THE SHOW.
DROP YOUR LOCKS IN THE CHAT
RIGHT NOW.
WE WILL BE GRADING YOUR PICKS AT
THE END OF THE SHOW, BUT WE NEED
YOUR HELP TO BUILD THIS
DIVISIONAL ROUND ANY TIME
TOUCHDOWN PARLAY.
RYAN, TELL THE PEOPLE WHAT WE
NEED.
>> WE NEED YOUR LOCKS.
IT IS FOUR THIS WEEK.
>> ONE FROM EACH GAME.
ONE FROM EACH GAME.
>> I AM NOT GONNA PLEAD FOR
JUICE.
WE'RE GONNA GET PLENTY OF JUICE
IF THIS IS FOUR LEGS.
>> I LIKE THAT.
>> COME IN AND LET US KNOW YOUR
LOCKS.
IF YOU LIKE BOSTON SCOTT, MAYBE
WE SAY YES THIS TIME.
EVERY TIME WE SAY NO HE SCORES A
TOUCHDOWN.
ONE FROM EVERY GAME.
HOPEFULLY THIS PARLAY LASTS
UNTIL TOMORROW, AND HOPEFULLY WE
RIDE OFF INTO THE SUNSET.
HOPEFULLY IT DOES PRESIDENT DIE
THIS -- DOESN'T DIE THIS
AFTERNOON.
>> MAYBE WE SHOULD PLACE THE
FOUR-LEGGER AND THEN PLACE THE
TWO-LEGGER WITH TOMORROW'S GAME.
>> SHOULD THOUGH -- SHOULD THE
TWO-LEGGER TOMORROW BE THE SAME
TWO LEGS WE USE IN THIS ONE?
>> TODAY?
OH.
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
>> PROBABLY.
>> YEAH.
PROBABLY.
IF YOU'RE CONFIDENT, YOU HAVE TO
BE CONFIDENT, RIGHT?
>> SO SHOULD WE GO -- SHOULD WE
START GAME BY GAME AND HAVE
JAGUARS AND CHIEFS AND BOOM,
BOOM, BOOM?
>> YEAH.
SAM, YOU'RE THINKING -- WE'RE
THINKING A LOT.
LET'S GO IN ORDER.
LET'S CONNECT DOTS.
>> SO WE'VE GOT DR. 87ZA JONES.
ALL EXCLAMATION POINTS.
TRAVIS KELCE.
>> CAN YOU UNRAVEL IT ON THE
SCREEN SO WE CAN SEE THE ODDS?
JONES IS DOWN HERE PLUS 200.
ON A REGULAR SLATE, REGULAR
SEASON SHOW I WOULD BE ALL OVER
THIS PLUS 200.
I LOVE IT.
BUT WE NEED TO SEE ONE GO
THROUGH THE HOOP, ESPECIALLY ON
THE FIRST ONE.
>> WE HAVE TO SEE ONE GO THROUGH
THE HOOP.
YOU GUYS KNOW WHO I LIKE?
McCKINON HAS BEEN BALLING.
>> I KNEW YOU WERE GOING TO SAY
THAT.
>> I HAVE A CONTROVERSIAL ONE,
UNDER THE RADAR.
TRAVIS KELCE, NOT SOMEONE YOU
THINK OF FOR ANY TIME TV AND THE
JAGS DO STRUGGLE DEFENDING THE
TIGHTENED AND I CAN SEE KELCE AS
A GOD.
IF WE DID WANT TO START OUT WITH
A NICE LEG TO GET THIS GOING, I
DON'T THINK IT IS THE WORST
OPTION IN THE WORLD.
>> WE HAVE DGX DROPPING MCKINNON
AS WELL AND SWIFT 218, NO.
11AD11 HAS DROPPED SEVERAL
TIMES.
HE ADDS AN EXTRA ONE AT THE END
OF -- HE ADDS AN EXTRA ONE AT
THE END OF INGRAM EVERY TIME WE
DON'T READ HIS COMMENT.
I'M WITH YOU ON TRAVIS KELCIE.
I AM GETTING READY TO ASK THUMBS
UP OR DOWN.
FOR THE PEOPLE EXPANDING THE
CHAT WITH JONES AND INGRAM, CAN
YOU GIVE AS YOU GOOD REASON WHY
THAT IS A BETTER BET THAN TRAVIS
KELSEY TO SCORE A TOUCHDOWN?
I CURRENTLY CAN'T FIND ONE.
>> I THINK IT IS RIGHT THAT IT
IS A BUMMER IF WE HAVE THIS
FOUR-LEGGER.
WE WANT TO START THE WEEKEND
WHERE WE STAND A CHANCE.
>> WE HAVE A SCOOP ALERT.
WE HAVE A SCOOP ALERT.
YOU SAW THAT?
>> A DEFENDING TIGHTENED.
YOU KNOW, I THINK KELCE MIGHT BE
THE MOVE.
START OFF WITH A WINNER AND GET
THE JUICES FLOWING AND STKPWRAB
A -- GRAB A COUPLE BEERS OR
WHITE CLAWS AND SIT BACK AND
RELAX AND ENJOY KELCE SCORING.
>> BEERS AND WHITE CLAWS?
CAN YOU MIX THEM?
>> SOME ARE BEER PEOPLE AND SOME
ARE CLAW PEOPLE.
I'M ACTUALLY A CLAW GUY.
ACTUALLY A HIGH NOON GUY.
>> SO WE'VE GOT HEARTBREAK -- GO
AHEAD.
>> SHOULD WE DO THUMBS UP OR
THUMBS DOWN OR JUST UH -- ASSUME
IT IS KELCE?
>> I THINK WE ARE LOCKED IN, BUT
WE CAN DO THUMBS UP AND THUMBS
DOWN IF YOU WANT.
>> CAN WE DO IT AFTER THE
GIANTS/EAGLES ONE?
THIS SHOULDN'T BE A DEBATE.
>> RIGHT, RIGHT.
>> I'M ACTUALLY GLAD WE GOT RYAN
ON BOARD WITH THIS.
>> I KNOW.
>> I DON'T WANT TO DELAY
BUILDING THIS PARLAY, BUT LAST
NIGHT I'M SITTING AROUND AND
THINKING IN MY HEAD, IF WE TOOK
THE CHALKIEST PLAY FROM EVERY
ONE OF THESE GAMES FOR A
FOUR-LEGGED PARLAY WHAT WOULD IT
BE AND I WAS GOOD WITH IT.
AS LONG AS YOU HAVE A GOOD
REASON -- I PREPARED MYSELF.
SO AS LONG AS YOU HAVE A GOOD
REASON I'LL BE ON YOUR SIDE.
>> YOU HAVE TO PREPARE YOURSELF
EVERY NIGHT BEFORE THIS SHOW.
I LOVE THIS ENERGY.
>> THE CHAT BY THE WAY, ALL
THUMBS UP HERE.
LET'S GET TO GIANTS AND FR --
AND THE EAGLES.
JALEN HURTS IS INJURED.
HE IS PLAYING, BUT HURT.
>> HE IS NOT OFF THE INJURY
REPORT.
>> THEY ARE LYING.
>> I AM WITH YOU TO THE EXTENT
THAT WE DON'T FULLY KNOW HOW
HEALTHY HE IS.
>> YEAH.
>> I'M GONNA SAY, I DON'T MEAN
TO MESS UP THE JUJU, BUT SAY
KWAN BARKLEY -- SAQUON BARKLEY
IS SCORING TODAY.
>> WE HAVE SAQUA -- SAQUON FROM
MARK RITTER.
I HAVE REASONING BEHIND THIS.
I HAVE BEEN BETTING THIS GUY TO
SCORE A TOUCHDOWN FOR WEEKS AND
HE MADE ME RICH.
EYE -- ISAIAH HODGES IS AT PLUS
265.
I KNOW YOU LOOK AT THAT AND YOU
GO, WELL, IT IS 265.
LET ME PULL UP HIS NUMBERS.
HE SCORED LAST WEEK.
I KNOW HE IS A LITTLE BANGED UP
WITH THE ANKLE.
HOLD ON.
LAST WEEK HE SCORED A TOUCHDOWN.
AGAINST INDIANAPOLIS HE SCORED A
TOUCHDOWN.
AND DECEMBER 24th.
DIDN'T SCORE ON
DECEMBER 19th AND HAD TWO
STRAIGHT WEEKS AFTER OF -- AFTER
THAT.
SINCE HE JOINED THE GIANTS AND
SINCE HE STARTED GETTING TARGETS
HE HAS ONLY NOT SCORED IN ONE
GAME.
>> I DON'T HATE IT, BUT I DON'T
THINK YOU WILL BE ABLE TO GET
THE CHAT TO GO WITH HODGES WHEN
YOU HAVE SAQUON AND DEVONTE
SMITH WHO IS ON FIRE.
>> I WILL SAY, GREG, AS THE MAN
OF THE PEOPLE, LOOK AT THE CHAT.
OKAY, WELL, I DIDN'T WANT TO
READ THAT ONE.
THE RAT IS RIGHT.
HAHA.
I LIKE ISAIAH FOR REAL.
BATTY BOY SAYS YES RYAN AND YES
HODGES.
MICK TARIO SAYS LOCK IT IN.
I'M TELLING YOU -- I'M TELLING
YOU --
>> DO YOUR THING, RYAN.
DO YOUR THING, MAN.
LET'S GO.
>> WOW.
>> HEY, RYAN, THAT'S HOW YOU GET
THE PEOPLE TO BACK YOU UP.
>> YES.
>> SEE?
>> WOW.
>> HE JUST LOCKED IT IN AND
MOVED ON TO THE NEXT GAME, NO
THUMBS UP AND NO THUMBS DOWN.
THE CHAT WILL NOT LIKE THAT.
>> THIS RYAN GUY IS TRULY CHERRY
PICKING.
WE ARE ON TO SUNDAY, BUT THUMBS
UP AND THUMBS DOWN THIS PARLAY
SO FAR.
I WILL SCROLL UP FOR EVERYONE.
IT IS TRAVIS KELCE AND TRAVIS
HODGES, CURRENTLY AT TWO TWO
LEGS:  THUMBS UP OR THUMBS DOWN.
>> WHILE WE GET THE THUMBS UP OR
THUMBS DOWN, ARE YOU SEEING THE
BOSTON SCOTT LOVE IN THE
COMMENTS?
>> THIS IS I -- THIS IS MY
ISSUE.
EVERYONE IN THE WORLD IS ON
BOSTON SCOTT.
I LOVE BOSS -- BOSTON SCOTT WHEN
YOU ARE NOT THINKING BOSTON
SCOTT.
>> MICHAEL RITTER DID A MEME AND
THEN IT'S OVER.
>> IT'S OVER.
THE SECOND THAT RITTER GIVES A
TAKE ON ANY TIME TOUCH TKOUP YOU
KNOW IT'S COOKED.
>> IT'S COOKED.
IT IS MIXED, HONESTLY.
>> YEAH.
I WAS TRYING TO GET A READ.
IT IS LOOKING MIXED.
SKWREU WE DON'T COUNT RITTER.
NO ANY TIME TOUCHDOWNS.
>> IT IS MORE POSITIVE THAN I
EXPECTED TO BE HONEST.
I THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO BE 90%
NO.
>> THE ONLY THING IS MOST OF THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE SAYING NO ARE --
DO BOSTON SCOTT INSTEAD OF
HODGES.
IT IS NOT LIKE WE ARE GETTING DO
AJ BROWN, DO MILES SANDERS AND
DO SAQUON.
IT IS THAT OR -- RITTER SAYS IT
IS CAVED.
IT IS EITHER THAT -- HODGES OR
--
>> SHOULD WE PUT SOMEONE ELSE IN
THERE AND SEE HOW THEY REACT?
MAYBE WE THROW IN SAQUON OR
DEVONTE SMITH.
>> THAT'S A GOOD READ, SAM.
>> I THINK THE ONLY OTHER ONE WE
DISCUSSED WAS SAQUON.
>> MY THICK -- MY THING IS WHY
ARE PEOPLE SECOND GUESSING
TRAVIS KELCE?
THEY SAY HE HASN'T SCORED, SO
THAT MEANS HE IS DUE.
>> AND IT IS THE MATCH UP.
HE HASN'T SCORED AND HE IS THE
BEST PLAYER ON THE FIELD OR
WEAPON ON THE FIELD.
>> IS FLETCHER COX -- FLETCHER
COX IS PLAYING.
IS JORDAN DAVIS PLAYING TODAY?
>> I BELIEVE SO.
>> LET ME LOOK IT UP.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> THEY SAY WE WERE SAYING AJ.
I HAVEN'T SEEN IT, MAN.
>> WHAT ARE WE TALKING ABOUT?
DO WE NOT WANT TO DO SAQUON
BECAUSE OF THE DEFENSIVE TACKLES
PLAYING?
>> THOSE GUYS ARE NASTY UP
FRONT.
>> SO IS SAQUON.
THEY ARE NASTY UP FRONT THOUGH.
>> IT'S TOUGH, MAN.
>> THE WAY THAT WE'RE SEEING
THIS -- THE WAY THAT YOU'RE
SEEING THIS GAME, SAM, I SEE IT
DIFFERENTLY.
I THINK THE GIANTS WILL NEED TO
THROW THE BALL MORE THAN THEY
PROBABLY WOULD LIKE TODAY.
>> I AGREE WITH THAT.
I HADN'T TAKEN THE EAGLES TO WIN
THIS GAME.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
IT IS TOUGH.
>> I THINK WE HAD H -- HODGES
AND ARE COOL WITH IT.
I THINK WE GOT ENOUGH --
>> I'M DOWN.
I'M DOWN TO KEEP HODGES.
IF GREG IS ON BOARD WITH KEEPING
HODGES.
>> THE PEOPLE SPOKE.
>> YEAH.
IT WAS LIKE 50/50 WHICH IS
PRETTY GOOD FOR A PLUS 365.
I'LL SAY THAT.
>> LET'S GET TO BENGALS AND
BILLS.
>> LET'S DO IT.
>> THIS GAME IS GOING TO BE
TRICKY.
>> NO.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A SHOOTOUT,
BRO.
WE GOT OPTIONS HERE.
>> YOU THINK SO?
>> YES.
WE HAVE JAMAR CHASE AND WE HAVE
STEPHON DIGS AND GABRIEL DAVIS?
>> THIS IS ACTUALLY THE SPOT
WHERE I WOULD BE MORE LIKELY TO
GO JUICY.
I HAVE TO GIVE RYAN CREDIT.
HE HAS BEEN IN ON THE TIGHT ENDS
AND EVERY TIME I LOOK UP DAWSON
AND SHULTZ ARE SCORING
TOUCHDOWNS, EVERY TIME.
>> WE'RE GETTING ALONG A LITTLE
TOO WELL TODAY.
I WILL SAY THIS.
THE VIBES ARE A LITTLE TOO HIGH
RIGHT NOW.
NOT TO BE A VIBE KILLER.
>> THAT'S A GOOD THING.
>> I KNOW.
>> MAYBE THROW KNOX IN THERE
AND, YOU KNOW, MAYBE WE REVISIT
GIANTS/EAGLES.
>> I KNEW THERE WAS A CATCH TO
ALL OF THIS.
>> WELL, I MEAN, WE COULD GO --
IF WE GO KNOX AND SHULTZ, IS
THAT 20-1?
25-1?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT JUST
HAPPENED HERE.
>> SHULTZ IS NOT SCORING.
>> WE MADE TOO GOOD OF A PARLAY.
>> MY THING, TKPWR*EBG -- GREG,
NOT TO TALK ABOUT THIS GAME, BUT
FRED WARNER SCARES THE LIVING
HELL OUT OF ME.
>> THE BEST COVERAGE LINEBACKER
IN THE GAME.
>> THAT'S WHAT I MEAN.
AND I DOVE HRAL TON SHULTZ -- I
LOVE DALTON SHULTZ AND I KNOW
DAK LOVES DALTON SHULTZ.
>> RYAN, IT IS POSSIBLE TO PULL
UP THE ANY TIME TD'S FOR THIS
GAME?
>> FOR?
>> LET ME REFRESH THE PAGE.
>> MALCOLM BIRD SAYS NO ONE
WANTED TO KEEP HODGES, BRO.
YES WE DID.
>> WHAT ARE WE DOING?
>> THE PEOPLE SPOKE.
I GOT YOUR BACK, BRO.
THE PEOPLE SPOKE.
>> DO PEOPLE LIKE KNOX?
>> SOMEBODY SAID JAMES COOK.
>> BRO, JAMES COOK?
>> TEE HIGGINS.
>> I THINK THERE IS GOING TO BE
A SHOOTOUT.
>> BOWLING SAYS ONE OF THESE
QB'S IS SCORING ON GOD NO CAP.
>> WE COULD HAVE DONE WITHOUT
THE ON GOD NO CAP.
>> MY TAKE IS GOOD TOO, RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
>> THAT'S A TOUGH ONE.
>> IT IS TOUGH.
I DON'T NECESSARILY KNOW -- I
THINK JOSH ALLEN PROBABLY CAN
SCORE.
I DON'T KNOW IF -- IF WE'RE
TAKING JOE BURROW, THAT'S SOME
SERIOUS JUICE AND I DON'T THINK
WE NEED TO PLAY -- YEAH.
>> NO, NO, NO.
>> JOSH ALLEN, I DON'T HATE
THAT.
I NEED MORE TAKES FROM THE CHAT.
WE ARE GETTING JAMES COOK.
>> I DON'T HATE IS IT -- I DON'T
HATE T BUT I LIKE KNOX MORE.
>> ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT JAMES
COOK OR JOSH ALLEN.
>> COLE BEASLEY ANY TIME
TOUCHDOWN VIBES?
HE GOT HIS LAST WEEK.
>> OH.
>> THAT WAS FROM OUR FRIEND
MICHAEL RITTER.
>> LEAF JUST DROPPED A GOOD
POINT.
WE ARE FORGETTING ONE OF THE
GREATEST GIFT GOD HAS BE --
BESTOWED ON SPORTS BETTERS AND
THAT IS ELI APPLE COVERING
DIGGS.
HE SAYS BENGALS CORNERS ARE
COOKED, STEPHON DIGGS.
>> THAT IS A GOOD TAKE.
I DON'T MIND THROWING DIGGS IN
THERE.
>> WE OVERTHOUGHT IT A LITTLE
BIT.
SO WE ARE AT 1087 RIGHT NOW.
IF YOU ARE JUST JOINING US, IT
IS TRAVIS KELCE, ISAIAH HODGES
AND STEPHON DIGGS.
IS THIS THE GAME WE TAKE A
RUNNING BACK?
WE HAVEN'T TAKEN A RUNNING BACK
YET.
>> IN THE LAST GAME?
>> YEAH.
>> TAKE CMC AND CALL IT A DAY.
NAH, BUT, RIGHT -- RYAN, COLE
BEASLEY IS GETTING SOME LOVE IN
THE COMMENTS.
>> NO.
NO.
I CAN'T DO THAT.
>> DAWSON KNOX IS AS WELL.
>> I LIKE KNOX.
>> I DON'T HATE KNOX.
HOW ABOUT THIS, BEFORE WE MOVE
ON --
>> IT WOULD BE BREAKING THE
RULES SO WE WON'T DO T BUT I
WOULD RATHER HAVE DIGGS AND KNOX
AND KNOCKOUT HODGES.
>> CAN WE STOP DOING THIS?
>> IT'S JUST RISKY.
>> WHAT IS RISKY ABOUT THE
STATISTICS I READ YOU?
THERE IS NOTHING RISKY.
HE SCORES EVERY GAME.
>> IS THAT REALLY BREAKING THE
RULES?
>> IT IS BREAKING THE RULES
UNFORTUNATELY.
>> OH, OKAY.
>> OKAY, WAIT.
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO THIS LAST
GAME AND IT IS CMC OR POLLARD.
I AM GETTING SOME -- WELL, I
WOULD SAY THUMBS UP FOR -- HOW
DO WE WANT TO DECIDE?
DROP DIGGS OR KNOX?
>> YEAH.
>> DROP DIGGS OR KNOX AND
WHATEVER WE SEE MORE WE WILL
ROCK WITH IT.
>> HOW ARE WE COUNT STPH-G
CHERRY PICKING?
>> THE FIRST 10 PEOPLE WHO
COMMENT, WE WILL ADD THAT UP.
YOU HAVE TO GET IN YOUR COMMENT
QUICK IF YOU WANT YOUR VOTE
COUNTED.
>> OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
FAIR.
>> AND MIKE RITTER SAYS CMC IS A
GREEN GODDY FOR SURE.
THIS THINK IS BANK.
>> THEY SAY DROP DIGGS, DIGGS.
I SEE A KNOX.
I SEE A HIGGINS.
>> PEOPLE AREN'T FOLLOWING THE
RULES.
>> KNOX.
>> IT SEEMS A LITTLE MORE DIGGS.
>> YEAH.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU THOUGH.
IF HE COOKS ELI APPLE WE WILL
FEEL LIKE IDIOTS, BUT I AGREE
THAT I THINK DAWSON KNOX SCORES.
>> THIS PARLAY IS --
>> SO WHAT ARE WE DOING FOR THE
LAST ONE?
DO WE DO CMC BECAUSE HE CAME
THROUGH FOR US LAST WEEK?
>> WE LIVE ON A WEEK TO WEEK
BASIS.
>> HE IS ALSO ONE OF THE MOST
TALENTED GUYS IN THE LEAGUE.
>> NAH, I LIKE CMC A LOT, BUT
YOU KNOW WHO IS SNEAKY HERE?
IT IS TWO SNEAKY PICKS.
WE HAVE BRANDON AND GEORGE
KIT -- KITTLE.
>> KITTLE HAS BEEN A TOUCHDOWN
MACHINE.
BESIDES LAST WEEK, HE SCORES
EVERY WEEK.
THE ONLY PROBLEM WITH KITTLE IS
HE IS STILL ONLY -- HE IS
GETTING LIKE THREE TO FOUR
TARGETS A GAME.
THEY ARE ALL IN THE RED ZONE SO,
YOU KNOW, BUT HIS TARGET COUNT
IS NOT -- IT IS KIND OF LOW.
>> TALK TO US, RYAN.
>> WE ARE TALKING 49ERS.
>> LET'S CHECK THE ODDS.
>> IT IS GOING TO BE GOOD.
>> I WAS JUST GOING TO SAY, I
FEEL LIKE EVERYBODY IN THE CHAT
AND EVERYBODY ON THIS LIVE
STREAM, WE ALL KNOW WHO WE WANT
TO TAKE, RYAN.
WE ALL KNOW CMC IS THE PICK, BUT
, YOU KNOW, DO YOU HAVE ANY
BANTER TO THAT, ANY PUSH BACK?
>> THE ONLY PUSH BACK I HAVE IS
THAT WHOEVER I'M ABOUT TO SAY TO
YOU IS OBVIOUSLY GOING TO BE
BETTER ODDS, RIGHT?
IT IS NOT BETTER THAN CMC, MINUS
155.
IT IS NOT WORSE THAN THAT.
I THINK TONY POLLARD IS GOING TO
SCORE AND MAY SCORE MORE THAN
ONCE.
I THINK THIS IS GOING TO BE THE
TONY POLLARD GAME.
ZEKE DOES IT EVERY YEAR WHERE HE
BREAKS DOWN TOWARD THE END.
HE IS MORE OF A SHORT-YARDAGE
AND BULLDOZE THROUGH.
I THINK POLLARD IS HEALTHY AND
EXPLOSIVE.
>> WELL, THE PROBLEM IS THE
COWBOYS MIGHT GET SHUT OUT.
YOU HAVE TO FACTOR THAT IN.
FACTOR THAT IN.
THEY MIGHT NOT GET IN THE END
ZONE AT ALL.
>> YOU WANT MY ACTUAL, REAL -- I
KNOW THIS WILL NOT BE
ENTERTAINED.
DAK PRESCOTT HAS PLAYED IN THE
LAST FOUR PLAYOFF GAMES, AND THE
LAST FOUR HE HAS THROWN A
TOUCHDOWN PASS AND RAN ONE IN.
>> YEAH.
BUT IS DAK IS 35 H-FP -- 35-1.
>> IF WE DID DAK WHAT WOULD IT
BE?
40-1, 70-1.
>> THEY SAY YOU'RE BIAS, RYAN.
STOP IT.
SOMEBODY ELSE SAID CMC DESERVES
NO PUSH BACK.
>> AGREED.
>> PROBABLY CMC.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> DON'T YOU SAY LIKE -- WOULD
YOU SAY HODGES SCORES AND THEN
WE ARE LOOKING AT TOMORROW WITH
DIGGS AND MCCAFFREY 18-1 WE ARE
FEELING PRETTY GOOD.
WE ARE FEELING PRETTY GOOD
TOMORROW.
>> I FEEL LIKE ALL WE NEED IS
HODGES.
WE GET HODGES TO GET IN THE END
ZONE AND THAT'S THE THING.
>> WE HAVE A PRETTY GOOD PARLAY.
>> THE LAST 30 SECONDS I HAVE
GONE THE OTHER WAY.
EVERYTHING ELSE IS LOCK IN.
IF WE GET HODGES IN THAT MOMENT
IT COULD BE ELECTRIC.
>> IT WILL BE.
I WILL UNFORTUNATELY BE IN THE
AIR, 10,000 FEET IN THE AIR SO I
WON'T BE ABLE TO SEE THAT.
>> 30,000.
>> I WAS GONNA SAY, THAT'S VERY
LOW.
>> I NEED RYAN HERE.
THAT'S THE THING.
I NEED RYAN -- I NEED TO MEET
YOU IN VEGAS, MEET UP WITH YOU
IN VEGAS.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE FUN TOMORROW.
>> I'M IN ON THIS PARLAY.
I THINK IT IS GOOD VIBES.
I'M GLAD WE HAVE HODGES AND I'M
GLAD WE ARE HEADED OUT.
I'M IN ON IT.
>> JAMES WISEMAN, WOW, YOU
HAVEN'T BEEN BANNED BY THE NBA
YET?
JAMES WISEMAN HAS BEEN SAYING
THE 49 OTHER OFF -- THE 49ER
OFFENSE REVOLVES AROUND CMC.
I LIKE.
IT THE ODDS ARE HE WILL SCORE.
DO WE WANT TO DO THUMBS UP OR
THUMBS DOWN OR A DEAL OR NO
DEAL?
>> WHAT ARE WE -- IF WE DO
THUMBS UP, THUMBS DOWN, THEY
HAVE TO PUT WHAT THEY WANT
CHANGED, YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAY
STPH-G.
>> AND I DON'T WANT TO HEAR IT,
HONESTLY.
>> I LIKE THIS PARLAY.
I LIKE THIS PARLAY.
>> I FEEL LIKE WE FEEL TOO GOOD
ABOUT IT.
AND WE ALREADY ASKED ABOUT THE
HODGES LEG AND THERE IS ENOUGH
POSITIVE MOMENTUM THAT, YOU
KNOW, I THINK IT IS IN.
GREAT PARLAY, LIKE THE PARLAY.
>> DARRIAN 85, HOLD ON.
THIS GUY HAS BEEN ON MY SIDE FOR
WEEKS.
I LOVE DARRIAN.
JUMPS IN AND SAYS IT IS THAT
WEAK HOODIE HE IS WEARING
STOPPING HIS BRAIN FLOW.
DARRIAN, YOU ASK ME TO DRINK
MILK, I DRINK MILK.
WE HAVE BEEN VIBING FOR WEEKS.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
THE CHAT TURNED AGAINST ME.
IT IS A SAD STATE OF AFFAIRS
HERE.
>> I SEE THUMBS UP THOUGH.
WE ARE GETTING GOOD VIBES.
>> DR. 87 WANTS POLLARD.
I'M WITH YOU.
I'M WITH YOU IN SPIRIT.
I HONESTLY MAY DO THAT.
I HONESTLY MAY DO THAT ON THE
SIDE.
I'LL BET THIS AND BET THE OTHER
ONE.
>> I THINK WE ARE LOOKING --
LOCKING.
GIVE IT TO US ONE MORE TIME.
GIVE US THE PARLAY ONE MORE TIME
FOR THE PEOPLE WOULD JUST JOINED
THE SHOW.
>> ALL RIGHT.
IN THE FIRST GAME OF THE
DIVISIONAL ROUND WE HAVE TRAVIS
KELCE SCORING AGAINST THE
JAGUARS, MINUS 150.
LATER TONIGHT EYE SWRAEU --
EYE -- ISAIAH HODGES SCORES
AGAINST THE EAGLES.
TOMORROW, STEPHON DIGGS AGAINST
THE BENGALS AND COOKING ELI
APPLE AND THE LAST LEG CHRISTIAN
MCCAFFREY MINUS 155 AGAINST THE
TEAM HE WILL LOSE TO, THE DALLAS
COWBOYS.
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT ONE,
BUT MAKE SURE YOU TELL US ON --
TAIL US ON DRAFT KINGS AND IT
WOULDN'T BE A SHOW WITHOUT ANY
TIME BOOST MAGIC.
WE ARE BOOSTING JAMAR CHASE ANY
TIME TOUCHDOWN PLUS 130 TO PLUS
175.
SO GO GET IT NOW.
IT IS TIME FOR OUR BEST BETS.
IT IS TIME FOR OUR BEST BETS,
AND I'M GONNA GET STRAIGHT TO
IT.
I'M GONNA GET TO MY PICK.
I'M ROCKING WITH THE G MEN FROM
NEW YORK TODAY.
GIVE ME THE POINTS.
I'M NOT SAYING MONEYLINE.
I THINK THIS IS GOING TO BE A
CLOSE GAME.
I THINK IT WILL BE CLOSER THAN 8
POINTS.
I'M ROCKING WITH THE POINTS.
I'M ROCKING WITH SAQUON AND
DANIEL JONES AND THE BOYS GOING
TO PHILADELPHIA, WHO WAS ON A
BYE WEEK.
SOMETIMES TEAMS, YOU KNOW, WHEN
THEY COME OUT THE BYE WEEK THEY
COME OUT PLAYING SLOW.
GOING TO PHILADELPHIA AND THEY
WERE ON THE BYE WEEK, AND I'M
NOT GONNA SAY THEY WIN, BUT I
WON'T BE SURPRISED IF THEY WIN.
I'M NOT GONNA SAY THEY WIN, BUT
I WON'T BE SURPRISED IF THEY
WIN.
I'M GONNA BE BETTING THAT PLUS
8.
SAM, TALK TO US.
WHAT YOU ROCKING WITH TODAY?
>> I'M GOING HEAD TO HEAD
AGAINST YOU GUYS.
I GOT SOME INSIDE INFO THAT RYAN
IS ALSO AGAINST ME HERE.
I AM TAKING AN EAGLES/BILLS
MONEYLINE PARLAY AND PAYS OUT
MINUS 120 OR MINUS 125.
I'M ON THE OTHER SIDE OF YOU
GUYS.
I'M NOT BUYING INTO THE GIANTS.
DANIEL JONES LOOKED GREAT LAST
WEEK, BUT HE WAS PLAYING ONE OF
THE WORST TEAMS IN THE LEAGUE,
THE VIKINGS WHO WERE A 6-WIN
QUALITY TEAM.
SO I DON'T PUT TOO MUCH STOCK IN
THAT.
EAGLES HAVE BEEN ONE OF THE BEST
TEAMS ALL YEAR.
THEY ARE HEALTHY.
SORRY, THEY ARE GETTING
HEALTHIER, JOHNSON BACK, HURTS
BACK.
I THINK THE REST HELPS AND THEY
ARE AT HOME.
I JUST DON'T THINK THE GIANTS
ARE OF THAT CALIBER.
29th IN DEFENSE.
I DON'T THINK THEY'RE THERE.
AND THEN OTHER GAME I AM TAKING
THE BILLS MONEYLINE.
I JUST THINK THE BENGALS ARE
LUCKY TO GET PAST THE RAVENS
WHICH IS TELLING CONSIDERING
THEY WERE GOING AGAINST HUNTLEY.
THEY WERE OUT GAMED AND OUT
GAMED THE WEEK BEFORE WITH THIRD
STRINGERS.
I JUST THINK THE BENGALS ARE IN
ANOTHER CLASS.
ARE YOU LAUGHING SO I WILL STOP
MY HANDICAP AND KICK IT TO RYAN.
THAT'S MY PARLAY.
>> I AM NOT LAUGHING AT YOU,
BRO.
I'M LAUGHING AT THE COMMENTS.
THE CHAT IS HILARIOUS.
BEFORE I LET YOU GO, RYAN, I
HAVE TO SAY THIS.
I DON'T LIKE THIS PARLAY.
GREG DIDN'T GIVE RYAN NO PUSH
BACK ON ANYTHING.
SOMETHING ISN'T RIGHT.
>> IT IS WEIRD.
IT IS WEIRD THAT WE ARE ALL LIKE
TOGETHER ON THIS.
>> OBVIOUSLY THOUGH, WHEN WAS
THE LAST TIME WE HAD AN ANY TIME
TOUCHDOWN PARLAY STP WE NEEDED
THIS.
WE NEEDED TO COME TOGETHER AS A
FAMILY AND SAY THIS IS THE WEEK.
>> THIS IS THE WEEK.
>> YES.
>> I'M CONFIDENT THIS IS THE
WEEK.
>> RYAN, GIVE THE PEOPLE YOUR
PICK, BROTHER.
>> REAL QUICK, SAM, YOU HAVEN'T
EVER FADED NEW YORK BEFORE,
RIGHT?
>> I CAN'T REMEMBER.
I CAN'T REMEMBER ANYTHING.
>> WE'LL HAVE TO LOOK BACK.
GREG, YOU'RE A SMART MAN BECAUSE
YOU HAVE NOW SIDED WITH THE BEST
BET.
>> 500 OVERALL FOR THE NFL
SEASON.
>> WHO HAS FOUR FUTURES VERY
MUCH ALIVE BY THE WAY.
>> I DON'T.
I HAVE ONE.
>> ALSO, IF YOU WERE ONLY
TAILING THE BEST BETS YOU ARE A
RICH MAN OR WOMAN.
>> OR WOMAN.
>> EXACTLY.
YOU CAN SEE IT IN THE TKPWRAFPBS
PLUS 8.
I HAVE SEEN THIS STORY BEFORE
WITH THE GIANTS.
I HAVE DONE THIS SONG AND DANCE
AND IT IS THE SAME CHORUS.
THEY ARE NOT A GOOD TEAM, BUT
GUESS WHAT, THEY WILL GO INTO
PHILADELPHIA AGAINST A HURT
JALEN HURTS WITH NICK WHO IS A
POO-P POO COACH AND A LOUD
MOUTH.
>> YOU ARE LETTING YOUR HATE
INFILTRATE YOUR BETS.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
>> WHEN I SAY 8-2, ONE OF THOSE
LOSSES WAS THIS EXACT GAME.
THE GIANTS AND EAGLES AND I
THINK THE SPREAD WAS THE SAME, 7
AND A HALF.
>> YOU HATE PHILLY AND EVERYBODY
KNOW THAT'S.
>> I KNOW I HATE PHILLY.
GUESS WHAT.
THEY ARE NOT THAT GOOD.
THEY'RE NOT.
>> WHOA, WHOA.
THEY'RE GOOD.
THEY'RE GOOD, BRO.
>> NO.
THEY STINK.
I WOULD TAKE -- IF BOTH DANIEL
JONES AND JALEN HURTS WERE FREE
AGENTS TODAY I WOULD SIGN DANIEL
JONES TO A MEGA MAX DEAL.
>> THAT'S HORRENDOUS.
>> LOOK, CAN WE LIKE --
>> DANIEL JONES IS THE GUY.
DANIEL JONES IS THE GUY.
>> NO.
NO.
>> HE IS THE MAN.
>> BEFORE YOU TAIL RYAN, LOOK AT
WHAT HE SAID.
>> YOUR COWBOYS FANS ARE SAYING
DAN -- DANIEL JONES IS THE MAN?
THERE IT IS.
RIGHT ON CUE.
>> DANIEL JONES IS THE GUY.
HE JUST -- YOU KNOW, I GET IT.
I HAVE SEEN THIS WITH THE GIANTS
BEFORE.
THEY HAVE A NOT GOOD QUARTERBACK
AS THEIR QUARTERBACK WHO THEN
GOES INTO --
>> YOU JUST SAID HE IS BETTER
THAN JALEN HURTS EIGHT SECONDS
AGO.
>> YOU DID.
>> BECAUSE HE IS A CLUTCH AND HE
WILL BE A LEGENDth POST
SEASON.
>> YOU ARE OUT OF CONTROL, MAN.
YOU CAN'T EVEN GET YOUR OWN
TAKES STRAIGHT.
>> DOES THE CAP MATTER?
I DON'T THINK IT DOES.
>> THE PEOPLE IN THE COMMENTS
SAY THAT'S CRAZY.
Y'ALL ARE TROLLIN.
>> DR. 87, I'M NOT WITH YOU IN I
MORE, BUDDY.
>> RATS IN THE CHAT, PLEASE.
>> IF THEY COVER, THIS DOESN'T
MATTER.
AGAIN, YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND I
WALK INTO THE SHOW EVERY SINGLE
WEEK WITH AN AGENDA, A NARRATIVE
I AM TRYING TO PUSH.
THIS IS THE NARRATIVE I'M TRYING
TO PUSH.
THE GIANTS ARE BETTER THAN THE
EAGLES.
>> THE NARRATIVE YOU ARE TRYING
TO PUSH IS JONES IS ELITE AND
ALSO BAD.
>> THAT IS TRUE.
HOW DO YOU NOT UNDERSTAND THAT?
HE IS ELITE WHEN HE NEEDS TO BE.
SOME PEOPLE CALL IT CLUTCH.
I CALL IT ELITE FOR AGENDA
PURPOSES, BUT HE STINKS.
>> TAKE THE EAGLES/BILLS CHAT.
TAKE THE MONEYLINE PARLAY.
>> NO BECAUSE THE CHAT IS SAYING
YOU ARE TROLLING.
THE CHAT WANTS US TO BE FOR
REAL.
>> HE IS NOT TROLLING.
HE ACTUALLY BELIEVES THESE TAKES
SOMEHOW IN HIS OWN MIND.
I DON'T KNOW HOW, BUT HE DOES.
>> IT'S TOUGH.
>> ALL WE WANT IS THE GIANTS TO
COVER.
LET'S GET OUT OF HERE, MAN.
>> JUST WIN.
>> TONIGHT.
WELL, WIN, COVER, I DON'T CARE.
>> WIN.
WIN BECAUSE I DON'T WANT ALL OF
US TO WIN.
I DIDN'T LIKE THE VIBE.
I DIDN'T LIKE THE WHOLE -- I
DIDN'T LIKE WHAT YOU JUST DID
THERE TO END THE SHOW AND CUT ME
OFF THAT I AM A LUNATIC.
GIANTS MONEYLINE.
>> SORRY, RYAN.
I'M SORRY.
>> THE PEOPLE IS TELLING US TO
CUT YOU OFF.
>> IT MAY BE THE MOST ABSURD
COMMENT WHICH IS SAM RICHMOND
WHO THINKS THERE IS VALUE ON
ANYTHING HE BETS.
I SAY TO YOU, OF COURSE I DO.
EVERYONE SHOULD THINK THAT
AROUND ANYTHING THEY BET.
IS ANYONE GOING TO BET I DON'T
THINK THERE IS A VALUE HERE, BUT
I AM BETTING IT?
YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU ARE CORRECT.
I DO THINK THERE IS VALUE IN
WHAT I AM BETTING.
>> THERE IT IS.
SAM THINKS THERE IS VALUE IN
EVERYTHING HE IS BETTING.
RYAN IS ALL OVER THE PLACE.
HE THINKS DANIEL JONES IS A
SUPERSTAR.
>> I AM IN ONE PLACE.
GIANTS PLUS 8.
>> YEAH, BUT YOU ALSO JUST SAID
DANIEL JONES IS BETTER THAN
JALEN HURTS.
>> THAT IS TRUE.
THAT IS TRUE.
>> WE GOT A CUT ON THAT ONE.
MY NAME IS GREG IVORY.
NEXT TO ME IS SAM THE MAN --
WAIT.
HOLD ON.
I'M SORRY.
BEFORE WE GET UP OUT OF HERE,
RYAN, REVIEW THE PARLAY FOR
EVERYBODY.
ONE MORE TIME.
>> HAVE I TO READ THIS -- MY
THROAT IS GETTING DRY FROM THE
AMOUNT OF TIME I READ THIS
PARLAY.
>> BRO, I MEAN, THE PEOPLE WANT
TO KNOW.
THE PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW.
>> KELCE, ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN AND
HODGES ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN AND
DIGGS ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN AND
CHRISTIAN MCCAFFREY ANY TIME
TOUCHDOWN, FOUR LEGS, PLUS 1853
ODDS AND DRAFT ANY TIME BOOST
FROM THE MAGICIAN GREG HIMSELF
IS JAMAR CHASE AND ANY TIME
TOUCHDOWN PLUS 175.
OUR BEST BETS, GREG, SMARTLY ON
GIANTS PLUS 8.
DANIEL JONES FOR MVP AND
SPRINKLE ON THE DANIEL JONES FOR
MVP.
WE MISSED THAT IN THE GRAPHIC.
SAM IS ON EAGLES/BILLS MONEYLINE
PARLAY AND THEN THE KING OF THE
BEST BET, GIANTS PLUS 8.
DANIEL JONES IS ELITE.
>> RYAN, BEFORE WE GET OUT OF
HERE, SOMEBODY SAID SOMETHING
ABOUT YOUR MUSTACHE AND SHAVING
IT IF THE PARLAY LOSES.
DON'T YOU HAVE A BET ALREADY
WITH THE MUSTACHE?
>> THE REASON I HAVE A MUSTACHE
IS BECAUSE I LOST.
LAST WEEK WE BET ON THE
RAVENS/BENGALS.
I BET ON THE RAVENS AND HE BET
ON THE BENGALS AND WE KNOW HOW
THAT SONG AND DANCE WENT.
>> I THINK IF GIANTS DON'T
COVER, RYAN SHOULD SHAVE THE
MUSTACHE.
>> SO YOU WANT ME TO GO CLEAN
SHAVE?
THAT'S WHAT YOU WANT?
>> DO YOU LIKE MUSTACHE OR YOU
DON'T LICE MUSTACHE -- DON'T
LIKE MUSTACHE?
>> I DO -- GO BACK AND FORTH.
IT IS NOT A LOOK I WOULD DO
PERMANENTLY.
I LOST A BET.
SAM TEXTED ME AND SAID DON'T
MAKE ME ENFORCE THE --
>> BE A GOOD GUY AND TRYING TO
SAY YOU DON'T HAVE TO.
THE SEASON IS ENDING THIS WEEK
AND MAYBE YOU WILL HAVE TO DO A
FOOD CHALLENGE.
A LOT IS GOING ON IN HERE.
>> IT IS NOT HAPPENING.
IT IS COWBOYS MONEYLINE THIS
WEEKEND AND EVERYBODY KNOWS
THAT.
>> NO.
>> YES.
>> WE CAN MAKE A BET.
WE CAN MAKE A BET.
I NEED HANDLEBARS COMING DOWN
FROM THE MUSTACHE.
>> FROM ME?
>> IF THE 49ERS WIN.
>> HANDLEBARS AND CAN I GET CHIN
HAIR?
>> NO.
>> THAT'S MY NEGOTIATION.
THAT'S MY NEGOTIATION.
STRAIGHT HANDLE --
>> STRAIGHT HANDLEBARS WITH THE
STACHE.
>> IF THE NINERS WIN?
>> YEAH.
WHAT DO YOU WANT FROM ME?
>> THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
I DIDN'T THINK ABOUT THIS.
NOW I'M REMODELING YOUR FACE IN
REALTIME.
WHAT IS THIS?
WE'LL GO CLEAN SHAVE, GREG.
>> I AIN'T DID THAT IN A MINUTE.
ALL RIGHT.
WE WILL OFFLINE ABOUT THIS.
>> OH!
>> MY NAME IS GREG IVORY AND
NEXT TO ME IS THE MAN, THE MYTH
AND THE LEGEND AND I CALL HIM
SAM RICHMOND AND NEXT TO HIM IS
THE MAN WE LIKE TO CALL PRODUCER
RYAN.
HEY, YOU GUYS FOLLOW OUR PLAYS?
WE ABOUT TO GET RICH TODAY.
WE UP OUT OF HERE.
LET'S GO NINERS!